new york governor kathy hokel who was
installed just earlier this week
acknowledging nearly 12 000 more coveted
deaths in new york state than the cuomo
administration had publicized let's
bring in janice dean on the phone so
janice the numbers were in new york
forty three thousand four hundred it's
now fifty five thousand three ninety
five with the addition of these twelve
thousand deaths apparently uh these are
not only confirmed coveted deaths but
presumed coveted deaths as well what are
your thoughts
well this is not new information the
federal health officials have been using
the higher tally for many months in new
york but governor cuomo has been sort of
fudging the numbers from the very
beginning including with nursing homes
you know one of the reasons why i've
been so outspoken is because he did not
count those that died in the hospital
like my mother-in-law she contracted
covid in her assisted living residence
but she died in the hospital and her
number didn't count so the governor of
the new governor has decided to become
transparent this is her first sort of
move to say you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
record the actual numbers as opposed to
the ones that the other guy wants you to
think they are it's just brutal janice
in hokel's words there are presumed and
confirmed deaths
she says the public deserves a clear
honest picture
of what is happening there is so much
that about this story that we cannot
undo janice and your family so greatly
affected by all of this are you hopeful
are you hopeful that she will lead to us
to a better place in all of this
i'm going to give her a few days i'm
going to give her a little bit of time
but i'm already discouraged by the fact
that she still has howard zucker on the
payroll he is the health commissioner
he's also the author of the march 25th
mandate to put covet positive patients
into nursing homes and he also helps
cover up those numbers so the fact that
he is still around and he is you know
really the guy who hand in hand went
with
governor cuomo to
to
mislead us on covet death so she really
needs to clean house she says she's
going to do that but if i'm going to
believe her she has to get rid of the
number one guy or the number two guy and
that is our health commissioner howard
zucker you know we we know from uh
previous uh
new york uh state officials that uh
andrew cuomo allegedly undercounted
nursing home deaths by 50 or or maybe
even a little bit more than that uh
again
the the additional deaths here the 12
000 uh released by kathy hokel the new
governor uh do not appear to be
additional nursing home deaths but
janice you're making the point here that
even though they may not be
listed as nursing home deaths people
from nursing homes who went somewhere
else like a hospital and died
could be included in this count so
therefore this could up the number of
people who contracted and
coveted in a nursing home and then
subsequently passed
away correct but we need the
investigation to continue you know the
one thing uh that i want to make people
remember is that there are ongoing
investigations here in new york about
the nursing home
not only the you know the lying about
the death toll uh but the fact there are
other things that this governor did he
you know he gave nursing homes blanket
immunity so that no one could sue them a
day after he put that march 25th uh
order in place so there are many things
that this governor has to be
investigated for and i want that to
continue but this new number of the
twelve thousand that kathy hokel has put
forward you know i want a federal probe
into this uh the bytes administration
they decided not to go ahead with the
doj investigation not only into governor
cuomo but the other governors that put
coveted positive patients into nursing
homes so there seems to be a lot of
covering up uh that i think needs to be
looked at more closely
janice real quick final question is
we've got um brian kill me do you spend
a lot of time with standing by on the
ongoing coverage of afghanistan yeah um
no never janice how are you doing um you
know obviously we've we've all watched
you so closely throughout this and and
now that he is gone he's exited the
mansion there was the debacle with the
dog how how are you doing
well listen you know people think this
is somewhat of a victory i mean i've
been screaming for a year and a half now
that you know this governor is corrupt
and i think he's criminal i think a lot
of these charges that are going to be
forthcoming are going to be criminal
a lot of people laughed me off and told
me i was just the weather girl
so there is a little bit of
justification but
you know i'm going to hold her
accountable as well if she's not
forthcoming and transparent and if these
investigations don't continue i'm going
to scream just as loud as i did with the
previous guy
janice we appreciate you
janice thanks so much
always always good to talk to you thanks
jake thanks jd
i went to brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now